[Musique]
là on est au sous sol tout cela aurait
dû remis store directement à paris
boulevard sébastopol c'est effectivement
l'ouverture aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
beaucoup moins il fait une chaleur
complètement dingue
[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est devant
la nouvelle boutique shiomi boulevard
sébastopol à paris qui est juste là elle
a ouvert il ya pas longtemps il ya une
queue qui est énorme
la cure garde et hop elle va jusque là
bas elle fait tout le tour tout le monde
est venu pour voir un peu le nouveau
store shiomi des nouveautés alors aussi
omis vous connaissez on a déjà parlé il
ya les smartphones les tablettes et même
les scooters électriques a pas mal de
choses et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle que j'ai omis soit arrivée en
france alors on va essayer d'en savoir
plus d'ici peu de temps grasset pour
rentrer là dedans mais faire nous cache
pas trois heures de queue ça n'arrange
pas des masses il ya plein de nouveautés
ya plein de trucs à voir et ça c'est
super cool
[Musique]
cela en est avec saïd qui vient de faire
du shopping directement dans la boutique
alors déjà premières impressions la
boutique si au mit à l'intérieur bien
pas bien comment tu décrire ses classes
pendant que c'est
d'abord ouais tu trouves qu'il ya
vraiment un côté un peu parce que paris
attendait paul ok qu'est ce que croit
qu'il est aujourd'hui sans le
l'ouverture de la boutique j'ai vu
l'événement cela
ouais bon
sagan est sûre
garrigues la chaleur parce que là il est
parce que 18 heures tu arrives à 6h du
mat
il
vaches depuis 6h du mat tu attendais
devant la porte énorme alors du coup du
mois qu'est-ce que tu ajoutes a montré
un petit post une enceinte
ça s'est passé qu'adossé soutage ces
cadeaux sont ok up
ensuite j'ai
[Musique]
sorties aussi genia quade aussi
une paire d'écouteurs je les achetais
cela cesse et il me semble qu autre
chose une batterie externe
même si j'ai acheté au soleil avec toi
après des tricheurs il a déjà racheté
toit des smartphones shiomi ou pas
jamais je crois que c'est un truc que tu
pourrais acheter ça pourrait intéresser
surtout le mouvement qui vont chercher
mx ds ta quoi comme smartphone
aujourd'hui j'ai un honneur 6 aux
lancers x
ouais on est content ça va pendant ce
temps m
[Musique]
sa nouvelle on a réussi à montrer dans
le choc donc là derrière moi vous avez
l'airé de 1905 qui sont juste là mais
reprennent chose à voir il ya le mx ds
il ya pas mal de trucs aussi sûr
ces écouteurs ici là ya pas mal de
choses différentes on va faire un petit
tour il ya peu c'est dans cette boutique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on voit plein de choses déjà
effectivement gagné mx2 est ce vous avez
leurs ennemis 5 vous avez plein de
produits s'est complètement ya des
trottinettes des casques et il ya des
sticks à celle fille il ya énormément de
choses et tout ça vraiment pas cher tout
l'univers shiomi et là alors
effectivement les télés sont exposées
jusqu'au pouvoir regarder
ils vont peut-être qu'elle est pour
l'instant alors on sait que chez home il
ya une offre extrêmement large au niveau
de la tête
il ya des télés il ya des aspirateurs
pour l'instant par le pas de sens en
france pour l'instant on va parler
effectivement des casques des batteries
faisait des téléphones des choses comme
ça peut-être les tablettes et des choses
qui vont venir pour l'instant sept
premiers se tient en france il y en a eu
il n'y a pas très longtemps à barcelone
qui était présent pendant le
le mwc au février de cette année à sa
passe déjà là on est tout de suite on
est le 22 mai la cour de presse pour
annoncer un peu les grandes nouveautés
donc effectivement on vaccine glisse
déploie se développe
après l'espagne à la france ça va faire
des petits y aura probablement d'autres
pays qui vont arriver donc ça c'est
vraiment cool et c'est très intéressant
parce que les produits jusqu'à présent
il fallait les faire venir fallait les
importés par des revendeurs trouver la
global personnes là pour l'instant tel
pouvoir acheter directement en store
acheté sur internet sur le site est
directement traduit et ça franchement
c'est cool
vous allez avoir les équipes qui à côté
communauté côté fan qui va se développer
aussi énormément
donc ça c'est vraiment intéressant donc
on va suivre ça de très près jeune
artiste est de plus en plus et ex essayé
de tester assez rapidement le minix deux
aces pour voir un petit peu ce qu'ils
disent qu'ici les bien oui ou non on va
tester leurs ennemis 5 plus il n'ya pas
très longtemps d'ailleurs vous invite à
les revoir la vidéo si pas encore fait
et bien évidemment on va parler
énormément de shlomi parce que c'est une
marque est très intéressant de manquer
veulent et qui s'annonçait comme une des
marques qui fait devenir de plus en plus
fort qu'en france nos bras suivre ça de
très près l'état a tendance à rester
connectés à suivre un peu mes aventures
la voyez si l'appareil
cette jolie pièce à suivre tout ça de
très près vous avez bien sûr amener ces
jolies pousse à vous abonner à marquer
toutes vos questions suggestions
directement aux commentaires et puis on
va suivre ça de près merci à vous à très
bientôt
soyez sages
[Musique]